[Music]
No yeah
s'okay I won't hurt seeds I know right
you're the mind reader I can't read mine
I can barely understand my hunt BOTS
[Music]
really beautiful what you're really
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
family in that suit is just hose Charles
to you yeah it used to be bit beefier zu
can back me up in that one that's you
what's wrong
CGT I told you I saw Lady Jane
it's crazy
the meek man
please you have to let me out before
someone gets hurt
Liam let him out man shut up I got can
you drive No
yeah where you gonna have to chops can't
see more than 10 feet in front of these
face I've heard that
dude come on is just like a bike tell me
you've ridden a bike of course
what you doing
driving
this is so not like riding a bike soon
there wouldn't be any kids anywhere the
government wasn't afraid of what
happened to the ones that didn't make it
they were afraid of us because the ones
that survived changed Lu Bu are very
rare among the most powerful we're going
to a place where kids can live together
on the outside dealing with people who
would ever help us for us
for their safety and yours please turn
over your children this morning to know
you're hiding and you're smart enough to
be hiding I just didn't want you to be
afraid of me more that I try to control
it
more damage that I do
I can show you how to use your strengths
the way they're meant to be used
[Music]
we can play back
we don't have to stay in darkness
we've survived all of this
I will fight for all of us
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna tell your story okay
so it's summer in Salem and you're
suffering through another boring on July
working part time with the ice cream
parlor you have earbuds in music blaring
one day your dad says hey let's go to
Virginia Beach
[Music]
and then as fate would have it I spot
you
you're walking towards me
[Music]
you beautiful
[Music]
what happened sex
if you can hear this you're one of us if
you're one of us come find us
the government was afraid of us because
the ones that survived changed the
darkest minds is about a world where the
majority of the population of children
has died and kids who are left powers
it's so much about standing up for what
you believe in the only people who would
ever help us for us we're going to a
place where kids can live together on
the outside the only way for the kids to
make it is together the kids Ruby emits
on her dirty inspires her strength we
don't have to stay in darkness we can
fly back to protect our greatest cause
us idiopathic adolescent acute
neurodegeneration or IAA nearly 90% of
the country's children are now survivors
of the virus developed side-effects or
what some are calling powers unexplained
incidents involving surviving children
continue to pour in from across the
country now go live to president grace I
am speaking today as a parent will find
a cure and save our children if you can
hear this you're one of us if you're one
of us the government's afraid of the
ones who live but we don't have to stay
in darkness
the only ones who could help us are us
we're ready for you we don't have to
stay in darkness the only ones who could
help us are us
Ruby is trying to figure out how to
survive in these circumstances we're
going to a place where kids can live
together on the outside why should I
trust you
we're your best chance of getting home
there's a deep understanding and Trust
develops between them I just want to
give you these a peace offering
there's an immediate chemistry between
them and they feel really strongly for
each other the more that I'd feel free
the more damage that I do I can show you
how to use your strengths the way
they're meant to be used
I know you
[Music]
you owe me I know how to but the only
ones who could help us are us the
darkest minds is about a world that is
very similar to our own
except that the majority of the
population of children has died you've
survived the sickness but you're not the
same all kids are given a color
assignment that corresponds to their
disorder Green's enhance intelligence
Blues have telekinetic abilities golds
can manipulate electricity Red's the
most destructive in oranges mind-control
drop it because of the powers the adults
are afraid of them who be children like
you are considered too dangerous
they catch you they'll kill you it's
about friendship and family it's kind of
like the dysfunctional family but as
good as you're gonna get these days
right it's so much about just being like
strong in yourself and standing up for
what you believe in and fighting for
what you believe in I will fight to
create a better place for all of us
[Music]